a game of bat and mouse in the u.s over
coronavirus research findings and public
funds quite literally a top national
institutes of health official has
admitted u.s taxpayer money finance
testing mice in china with back
coronavirus genetically altered to make
it more transmissible to humans now the
danger of such research has always been
that the virus could escape the lab and
spark a public health disaster the
limited experiment described in the
final progress report was testing as
spike proteins from naturally occurring
bad coronaviruses circulating in china
were capable of binding to the human
ace2 receptor in the mouse model
laboratory mice infected with the
chco14 double
bad coronavirus became sicker than those
infected with wiv1 that coronavirus
ecohealth failed to report this finding
right away as was required by the terms
of the grant and yet for months the
biden administration's big cheese on the
disease dr anthony fauci denied any
claims that the u.s funded such projects
it comes as vindication for republican
senator rand paul whose quest for
transparency on the investigation was
beginning to look like a rat race no
one's saying those viruses
those virus caused the pandemic what
we're alleging is that gain of function
research was going on in that lab and
nih funded it that is away from it it
meets your definition and you are
obfuscating the truth if anybody is
lying here senator it is you
some experts say fauci knowingly misled
the country
the national institutes of health's
acknowledgments of the facts is new but
the facts themselves are not new the
national institutes of health was
informed about the gain of function
research in wuhan in 2018 and again in
2020. collins and fauci lied to congress
lied to the press and lied to the public
now although the bat is out of the bag
according to tayback's letter it seems
that the u.s has tried to cover up
anything indicating any links to such
research in wuhan the us-based
eco-health alliance president peter
dashak was even chosen as part of a
whole team of experts to investigate the
origins of kovid but it seems that much
of u.s top level efforts in the pandemic
not least their insistence on blaming
and investigating china have only
exposed u.s official cover-ups and lies
with a disturbing question being why are
cover-ups and lies needed
you